hello everyone and welcome to what is
that one of the nicer games that have
seen so far in the 2018 World Chess
Championship it's again between Peter
Svidler and Metreon Drake and both of
them have been having an excellent
tournament so far but as this is round
10 so this is the end of the second day
I went in this round means really really
well a lot and after seeing this game
you will really wonder will you ever be
able to enjoy classical time form it
again but without further ado let's
check out this very nice game Spindler
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to f3 and I decided to show this
game as soon as soon as I saw it in the
life coverage but I've seen some of you
already suggested in the comments so I
guess it's a it's a nice win-win
situation Knight to f6 so the reti
opening is on the board c4 b6 we have a
g3 and now Bishop to b7 Bishop to G 2 G
6 and we have castles here c5 III this
is well pretty standard everything 440
English opening that is now on the board
Bishop to g7 and now d4 we have castles
from Knight to c3 and now Knight to e4
trying to trying to exchange an eye for
night here spoiler doesn't want to trade
he goes Knight to e2 prepares to go
Knight to a4 and we have Knight to c6
here Knight to a4 by settler and here in
this position in in 1976 there is a very
nice game where oil of chikki every
defeated effing Geller with rook the c8
but we have east sex here by and rakin
which perhaps means that I'm taking is
still in the in the well in inside book
that he is still inside his line of
preparation as east X's preferred by the
engine to rock the c8 but okay rook to
e1 voice littler although you could try
d5 but it's still too early for D fun
the night will come to a five attacks c4
year you can go b3 as the bishop is
attacking it here you'd have to defend
Queen c2 it might be possible but
fitler decides to go rookie one first
there's always time to go d5 and doesn't
really do anything for black to exchange
on d4 we have F 5 by Andre Caen and now
comes d5 now it's a different story
because now if you if you go night at
5:00 then you can even capture on e6 s
now the f1 is no longer defending it but
we have it captures on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and now comes Knight to
e7 putting pressure on the d5 not under
d5 Knight Knight back to e for not
allowing exchanges and here black is
defending the d5 square plenty of times
but he still can go d5 do 296 with with
a nice fork here so after night at 4
Queen to c7 and now comes a 4 by sliver
a very nice move grabbing more space on
the Queen side at some point you will
move the rook perhaps you will be three
you can maybe put the bishop on this
nice diagonal to counter blacks very
strong bishop but also perhaps a very
nice rook lift which rook to a3 to d3
will be possible in the future but black
decides to take initiative we have g5
attacking the knight here Knight goes to
h5 attacks the bishop on g7 and now even
g4 and here it would be it is impossible
to capture the very strong Russia
because here pawn captures and your
Bishop is attacked as well as your
knight here and there are no good good
jumps with the night
so after g4 we have 90 to h4 and now
comes Knight to g6 and here while you
could capture the Knights wheeler
decides to capture the dark square
Bishop and I mean who wouldn't 9th
capture some g7 now we have Knight
captures on h4g captures on h4 King
captures on g7 and now comes Queen to c2
this was well this was one of the more
critical moments in the game perhaps
even the critical moment as it is
essential to play b3 here you want to
play b3 as it immediately prevents black
from executing the plan that was
executed in the game which is rook to f6
to h6 because now rook to f6 is
impossible due to bishop pinning the
rook and well winning material but also
it's just a very nice diagonal to have
the bishop but this little or first
decided to go Queen to c2
but then after up to f6 b3 was played
but now black already managed played
this rook to h6 move and attack White's
doubled h4 pawn with Bishop to b2 this
comes with check King to f7 and now it's
it's a very unpleasant position for
Sevilla here he played Bishop captures
on e4 we rush up captures on e4
attacking the Queen and now comes Queen
to c3 now of course you don't want to
allow Queen to g7 check picking up the
rook and h6 so first rook to g8 bring
your last inactive rook into the game
and here this is the critical moment of
the game but not really as that b3 move
was so crucial that I will I will make
that at the critical moment of the game
and I in fact think it is here you have
to play Queen to e5 but it's not going
to help you it will prolong the game
hard to say if it's possible to even
continue this but having this beautiful
Queen Bishop battery along this dark
square diagonal not allowing black even
to think about capturing on h4 as you're
just gonna pick up with Queen to f6 it's
a if you miss blacks next tactic then
it's possible to not play Queen e5 here
so it'll played a5 but the move is
actually deciding the game immediately
here black has a deciding attack it's
it's a force checkmate in six moves so
feel free to pause the video and find
the move sailor missed well I enjoy my
nice sip of water so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent sacrificer of the
Queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show the movies Queen
captures on h2 that's right that's
that's the move it's a very nice move
you have to accept the Queen or you
don't I mean the the outcome is the same
but it is the best defense if King to a
fondant Bishop to f3
not allowing the King to escape and
there's no defense against Queen to h1
so you will have to capture the Queen
King captures here and the now comes
rook captures on h4 with check again you
can't go to g1 the bishop is controlling
this diagonal
Rock - h1 will deliver checkmate so
after this check you have to go up the
board King the g3 was played you have
looked to h3 check King to f4 look to f3
check this is all forced King to e5 and
hereafter look to g6 at this is a move
29 so really a very nice miniature a
Peter Svidler resigned the game why did
you resign well whatever he does it's a
meeting one let's say you decide to
capture a pawn then you get the d6 this
will be checkmate as you can see the
King has nowhere to go
the rock is controlling the f4 squared
the pawn is controlling this Square and
everything else the bishop is
controlling the LightSquared the King is
controlling these squares so not
possible and even if you prevent the
pawn from coming to d6 let's say you go
Luke 81 then roopd 6 another very nice
checkmate and there are no there are no
there there isn't even a possibility of
prolonging the game after Luke to g6 for
more than one move so a beautiful game
by meteor and raking won one such game
that is well very unlikely to happen in
a classical time format so that's why
it's always enjoyable when when such
strong players gets together for a nice
brawl in faster time controls and after
one more day of rapid then we are then
we're gonna be treated to two days of
blitz which will be completely insane
and I can't wait for that at the start
but yeah really an excellent game like I
said both of them were having an
excellent tournament so far and now
we're gonna check out the standings
after round 10 some of you have asked in
the comments section where can you check
out the standings you can go to well a
lot of websites offer this I don't know
I use chess results calm you just type
test results rapid or something in a
search bar and it will be the first
thing that that appears so this is a
like I said the the the rank after
rounds 10 as it says up there in first
place with seven and a half points we
have a shared and a lot of people are
sharing this Napoleon as you said I was
pronouncing his last name incorrectly
previously but I do believe it's in upon
Yoshi
then meet Leon Drake in one cow new
youngie Vladislav Artemyev done he'll do
both and Maxine Malakhov with seven and
a half points Sharma Madera was also
having an excellent tournament for the
entire two days then he lost today I
believe in last round against Matlock
off then with seven points as you can
see our team team of five onigiri I
believe vanish jury still without a loss
Anton Caribe of Boris Gelfand Gregorio
Pauline David Anton Sally solemn fish
Manhattan and shark even magnus carlsen
ali reza firoozeh it's interesting even
charged to one a very nice game against
Vishwanathan Anand Anand blundered at
the end so but still a very nice game
again shot for even charge but then he
lost also a very nice game against yun
in policy and then we have ma media of
to watch the Matlock of alexandra Zubov
german baz if he Kara Nakamura severe
Carrick in Afghani Alex save and
pantalla Hari Krishna those were the
those are the 25 all of the 25 highest
ranked players after round 10 so there
we have it I do hope you enjoyed that as
well and that you have enjoyed this game
and once again congratulations if you
found that Queen captures on h2 move I
saw in the live feed when when thriller
saw this he was actually very happy that
if he is already going to lose that he
will lose well with with great style and
it definitely is the way to go if you if
you have to lose you know do it with
style so so a lot of people will see
your game and you know you will promote
chess so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank Allah
for roughly Thanos Sam Leonard channel
rod Riggs and Google Markie volver
volver different revision to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos see are think all for watching
and I will see you soon with some more
nice games from the 2018 rapid
championship
use that hashtag suggest to check out
more games and also be a part of the
subscribers video 2019 if you don't know
what it is I challenge you to find out
thank you all and I will see you soon